hi i'm jason sudeikis lost sorry i'm
anne hathaway and we're here to do the
wired autocomplete interview and between
the two of us we know all the words
people watching this for the internet
okay so the first one what Anne Hathaway
real name Anne Hathaway real name is
Annie
whenever anybody calls me and I just I
don't know I feel like they're mad at me
what is Anne Hathaway
wrong what does Anne Hathaway eat what
did Anne Hathaway win an Oscar for
emoting I did that for a single chair
what is Anne Hathaway like in real life
fine fine like this with not as bright
of lights
what is Anne Hathaway poem is this a
Shakespeare reference cuz Anne Hathaway
with Shakespeare's wife how about that
did your folks know that they did they
did I wasn't supposed to be on Hathaway
I was going to be Katherine Hathaway
which I'm very relieved that I wasn't
because of the way just yeah it gets
them let's see then what does Anne
Hathaway look like now a little tired
don't look a little wilted but also like
she has people who do her hair okay
does does Jason Sudeikis smoke weed
sure sure I was like ooh this is gonna
be a funny one as well when it's a whale
you know when it's legal when from
medicinal purposes it'd be rude to
refuse it illegal circumstances does
Jason's face have the virus the weed
smoking virus yeah that's why I have to
smoke it so they played drums yes but
not well I were out I'm not a drummer
but I own a drum kit what does Jason
Sudeikis like like this occasionally on
a beard yeah but more and more or less
like this
what does bass is a Dacus voice
Cleveland Show I was a couple voices on
there really yeah yeah
I played Holt and then Terry Holt was
kind of like this like kind of a little
short guy with the real deep voice and
Terry it was like Terry was southern guy
anything that has my voice on it
essentially goes away is Anne Hathaway
married yes is Anne Hathaway British no
that's a couple of three
I didn't mean to be pulled it off
somewhere is Anne Hathaway vegan not
anymore
is Anne Hathaway a vampire I mean I look
like one you would be forgiven for
thinking that but no it's cuz you wear
big hats it's Anne Hathaway an Oscar
winner yes yes is Anne Hathaway related
to Judy Garland no not related just a
fan okay
what is Jake and Sudeikis doing well
this this interview yes I'd those what
is Jason Sudeikis first moon the first
movie I ever did was a movie called
alien Avengers 2 it was a Roger Corman
production yep I mean like 3,000 bucks
I spent it all like in the first week
this one this whole thing this whole
thing it's long yeah
what movie jason sudeikis watching an
eastbound down kind of think it's Top
Gun I just know we referenced Top Gun a
lot what only one well I guess two of
you can't water but uh American Crew oh
I know that one that's really good I
really like the green stuff okay here we
go
we this watch this ready okay did Anne
Hathaway date Ellen DeGeneres I wish no
does Anne Hathaway know Bruce Wayne is
Batman now I do thanks thanks Internet
did Anne Hathaway wear a wig in the
stars yes
ish when the wench her hair is straight
it was my hair but the beginning part
where her hair was was lovely and it was
not my hair cuz my hair doesn't do that
did Anne Hathaway have braces I did yeah
nice braces first 14th didn't Anne
Hathaway really yes I did I really fall
it had just rained and
what you're talking about there's a
really big fall and I really did I fell
and I just I laughed and kept shooting
uh did Anne Hathway really sing Elena I
can't really sing unless that was me
okay
on to yours did Jason Sudeikis go to
Kiev no I wear the shorts I'm from
Kansas I support the basketball team I'm
jockeying for a honorary degree did
Jason Takes do an Applebees commercial
yes I did for a while I was the voice of
Applebee's see you tomorrow yeah it was
fun it was fun I think it's awesome that
you're the words of Applebee's not
anymore
this is the can yeah that really is
where Jason I went to to I went to
Rockhurst high school in Kansas City
Missouri and then I moved on to Shawnee
Mission West public school on the Kansas
side which I graduated from eventually
in the summer I failed
English does Jason Sudeikis have a
brother I do not have two younger
sisters I always wanted an older brother
what did chase Vegas play in did you
plan I played in Kevin Durant five
eyeballs and the NBA celebrity all-star
game two years ago that's a good deep
cut for the gentleman behind the camera
all right here we go where is Anne
Hathaway cottage stratford-upon-avon
England oh where is Anne Hathaway now
here right here on your computer or
tablet
where did Anne Hathaway it was restored
I would say the papermill Playhouse in
in Millburn New Jersey and I made $50 or
I think it was like 13 weeks of work
whereas Anne Hathaway at the end of
interstellar well that's a spoiler alert
but she's at the end of her rope person
to Google that she just finished movie I
know where is where was Anne Hathaway at
the - 2015 oh I was in New York doing a
play doing a production of the Public
Theater of the playground it is where
you actually know is Jason Sudeikis no
is Jason Sudeikis in the hangover
no you're thinking of Bradley Cooper you
they would be forgiven
I chase in cities from Detroit no I'm
from Kansas City but I helped produce a
show called Detroiters by a couple guys
from Detroit is Jason Sudeikis a
sneakerhead
yes I would say yes I've known this guy
for a long time he's a Jason Sudeikis
Lithuanian yes
my last name is Lithuanian like I don't
know much about the culture
unfortunately his Jason Sudeikis and
Mumford & Sons know that I wasn't a
video I was in a video for a hopeless
wanderer me and Ed Helmes thought I knew
you better than I apparently do this is
why the Internet's a good thing this is
maybe one of the only reasons